maxime tu préfères tu préfères capucines
à naves ou isabelle morini-bosc aa
attention la belgique non mais après ce
que je viens de dire isabelle isabelle
morini-bosc voilà alors ça m'aurait
arrangé
bah oui je suis mais on va mais on va
rattraper parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya
eu les appelle ça m'a fait plaisir ce
qu'elle me dire il ya eu il ya eu un
petit bijou avec capucine à temps il est
devenu le petit bisou tuvalu passé
d'extraits c'est cyril temin précis au
jour un bisou le bisou talonne vrai
après on fera le bijou mais avec
l'impression d'être approché capucines
ou à écouter l'appel de huit heures
faites vous un petit bisou
[Applaudissements]
ses pions je suis bien là le côté quoi
bien et avec isabelle les autres de
bussy n'arrêtait pas de dire ouais les
footballeurs dé plus de précision du
mont albert et les charpentiers ça rien
à voir donc voilà c'est ma cousine quand
même au cas où c'est vrai ben en même
temps de l'égalité est-ce que c'est ce
que voulait faire un petit bisou isa
mais pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais pas la [ __ ] pas là bas non il
attendait sur la semaine il faut le
soigner ou se contentent désaccord donc
en fait à chaque fois que ça nous
arrange ça comme on l'a pas encore celle
là je pouvais avoir maintenant ça les
arrangerait bien qu'ils jouent
[Applaudissements]